bonsoir c'est maintenant l'heure
d'auditions publiques notre rendez vous
en direct tous les lundis soirs sur lcp
assemblée nationale public sénat et le
figaro une heure en direct donc de
débats de confrontation d'interrogations
et nous recevons ce soir emmanuelle
wargon bonsoir vous êtes après terres
d'état auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire avec
des dossiers précis avoue sur lesquelles
on va revenir par exemple l'énergie
entre autres mais pas seulement on va
retrouver aussi dans quelques instants
nommé qu'on sort des chaînes
parlementaires qui viendront vous
interrogez deux parlementaires aussi
qu'ils auront des questions très
précises parce que ce sont des élus de
terrain qui ont aussi des expériences et
qui voudront vous en faire part
et puis yves thréard du figaro qui
viendra conclure l'émission avec ses
questions à lui plus des questions des
téléspectateurs que les téléspectateurs
peuvent nous faire parvenir sur
lefigaro.fr ou sur twitter avec le
hashtag auditions publiques ou figaro
live je vais commencer par une première
question je vais vous parler d'une femme
qui s'appelle isabelle kocher vous la
connaissez rares patronne du cac 40
quand même elle est la tête d'hadji du
groupe d'énergie angie son mandat prend
fin bientôt
la question est de savoir si elle va
être renouvelée ou pas l'état détient 23
% des bardes angie est ce qu elle a le
soutien de l'état pour un mandat
supplémentaire
je connais les abeilles kocher j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler avec elle c'est
effectivement une des seules femmes
dirigeantes du cac 40
et elle a pour elle une vraie vision de
la transition écologique et une vision
pour amener l'entreprise dans laquelle
elle est angie à l'après carbone et à la
mettre vraiment sur cette trajectoire du
jeu un bon bilan vraiment une vision
forte et une capacité stratégique forte
après c'est une décision qui se prend au
conseil d'administration l'état est
actionnaire mais n'est pas le seul
actionnaire l'état cherche le consensus
au sein du conseil d'administration
c'est en train de se décanter il ya eu
un conseil la semaine dernière le
conseil décisif sera je crois fin
février et c'est le conseil lui-même
elle a aussi besoin de la confiance de
ses actionnaires j'entends ps qu'elle a
la confiance de l'état qui est
actionnaire
encore une fois l'état a dit qu'il ne
n'iraient pas contre les autres
actionnaires et qu'il fallait un
consensus global au sein du conseil
d'administration mais à titre personnel
c'est quelqu'un que j'estime et que vous
soutiendrez à titre personnel j'ai bien
compris parce qu'elle a quand même un
sacré comité de soutien dans les échos
cet après midi plusieurs personnalités
ont signé en sa faveur
yannick jadot d'europe écologie les
verts anne hidalgo
cédric villani par exemple qui disent
yannick jadot par exemple qui dit
exactement comme vous elle a un bon
bilan elle a su aller vers les nouvelles
formes formé source d'énergie ça vous
étonne ce comité de soutien
je crois surtout qu'il faut que la
discussion en reste dans le conseil
d'administration maintenant son bilan
est connu d'ailleurs le conseil
d'administration a mandaté un cabinet
pour faire l'évaluation de ce bilan il a
maintenant tous les éléments pour
décider
je suis confiante dans la capacité du
conseil a décidé et ce comité de soutien
ça vous inspire quoi comme réaction
encore une fois je pense que la
discussion dans la discussion doit
rester plutôt au sein de l'entreprise
c'est une durée c'est une décision de
management de conduite d'une entreprise
cotée est donc je pense que la
discussion est bien à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise le doubs d'europe écologie
de vue vous imaginez qu'ils soutiennent
patrons du cac 40
en tout cas ce que ça peut vouloir dire
aussi c'est que la transition écologique
la transformation écologique on la fera
avec les entreprises et donc je trouve
ça plutôt bien - qu'europe écologie les
verts au delà du cas particulier
reconnaissent que la transformation
écologique elle se fait avec les acteurs
publics avec les citoyens mais aussi
avec les entreprises que les entreprises
doivent s'engager et qu'il faut soutenir
cet engagement on va cueillir maintenant
tomes traduits de public sénat et
brigitte boucher de cp assemblée
nationale
bonsoir tam et brigitte dans un brasier
sa fidèle au rendez-vous qui on va
commencer par ce qui fait débat en ce
moment tam
c'est ce congé cette proposition de
créer un congé pour les parents qui
subissent le deuil d'un enfant voilà et
d'allonger ce congé ça fait l'objet un
peu du couac de la semaine dernière il
ya eu le rejet de cette proposition de
loi par la majorité de la république en
marche à l'assemblée puis le
rétropédalage au niveau du gouvernement
du président de la république tout de
même vous auriez pu vous passer de tout
cela on a reconnu une erreur collective
politique c'est vrai que ce sujet est
passé vite dans une niche parlementaire
une proposition de loi et qu'on était
dans une logique qui en fait n'était pas
la logique de solidarité de compassion
nécessaire sur ce sujet et non seulement
nous avons non seulement nous avons
reconnu cette erreur mais nous sommes
prêts à retravailler puisque vous le
savez le gouvernement souhaite que cette
proposition de loi soient inscrits
rapidement au sénat elle le sera dès le
3 mars
les plus sages en tout cas c'est le sait
la nouvelle étape du débat parlementaire
a fait vous allez à cette occasion à
l'occasion de la suite normale de la vie
législatif de cette proposition de loi
on fera des propositions pour répondre à
la question posée de la bonne manière
trouver une manière d'allonger ce congé
à 12 jours et trouver les modalités de
financement de jeunes sur vous vous
parlez vous même d'une erreur collective
ça veut dire que vous assumez vous une
part de responsabilité en tout cas en
tant que membre du gouvernement de la
majorité
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se rende
compte quant à un moment on est pour
deux pour des raisons diverses et
variées décalées par rapport à
à une prise de position et qu'on est
capable de dire voilà on n'était pas
forcément sur la bonne position
nous sommes en train d'évoluer en fait
la question était aussi une question
technique de savoir si ça devait être
les entreprises la solidarité nationale
etc
on l'a pris de façon peut-être un peu
isolé on la reprend vraiment dans toutes
ses dimensions politique de solidarité
humaine et on est capable de dire oui la
copie est pas définitif peut pas être
définitif ça tout le monde est
responsable finalement quand on est le
kursaal et me laisse personne n'est
coupable ça a quand même été adopté en
commission il ya quand même un
responsable gouvernemental qui fait le
lien avec la majorité
il ya quand même eu tout un système qui
a qui a failli oui et non au sens où
d'abord cette proposition de loi n'a pas
été adoptée au moment du débat public
ça a permis de mettre les choses sur la
table le gouvernement et la majorité
disent aujourd'hui on est prêts à aller
plus loin et du coup on aura j'espère
une sortie par le haut de cette question
qui est un texte adopté
ça ne se reproduira pas à la douleur des
familles qu'on comprend tout à fait à la
fois c'est aller un peu vite et à la
fois il ya des cordes de rappel
démocratique qui font que le débat a eu
lieu qu'il n'est pas chez n'a en fait
qu'il n'est pas fini
quand vous entendez emmanuelle wargon la
députée la république en marche puisque
vous évoquez les entreprises tout à
l'heure du var sereine mauborgne déclaré
c'est trop facile de s'acheter de
générosité sur le dos des entreprises
comment vous réagissez à ça mais en fait
je pense que commença ses propos la
question posée de façon trop petit trop
fermé c'était si on le fait qu'ils
financent je pense qu'il faut qu'on
remonte à la question quelle est la
logique qu'est ce qu'on souhaite faire
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne des
parents qui sont dans qui sont dans le
village soit vraiment de deuil est
terrible et après la question de savoir
si ce sont les entreprises la solidarité
comment vos larmes discutions des biens
les mots c'est trop facile de s'acheter
de la générosité sur le dos des
entreprises
ça vous fait quoi comme moi j'étais
argile et d'entendre aussi j'etais
interrogatif quand j'ai vu
ce sujet se dérouler les quelques
derniers jours moi je suis heureuse
d'être dans un gouvernement et une
majorité qui dit voilà on a fait une
erreur collective
on va rectifier ça vous ne répondez pas
à ces propos ça fait ça vous fait froid
dans le dos ou pas mais on a tellement
de temps de débat parlementaire on a
tellement de prise de parole que oui moi
je ne formulerai pas les propos comme ça
je n'aurais pas dit comme ça
est ce que le problème ce n'est pas
aussi que vous refusez systématiquement
toute initiative qui ne vient pas de
voix ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu un
parti clanique ce qu'on a vu arriver là
c'était aussi arriver sur une
proposition de loi doré à prades et par
exemple sur les enfants handicapés est
ce qu'il n'ya pas ce problème là aussi
accepter la porte des autres
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
cas sur lesquels dans lesquels on est
capable d'avancer avec des propositions
loi de l'opposition mois sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments il
ya eu une proposition de loi portée par
boris vélo n'était pas d'accord avec le
mécanisme qui proposait mais on a dit
qu'on était prêt à tirer les leçons du
débat sur l'évolution des aides à la
rénovation donc il ya des tout à fait
des sujets sur lesquels on est prêt à
construire avec l'opposition on a
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de textes
notamment sur l'écologie c'était vrai
pour la création de l'office français de
la biodiversité c'est vrai pour la loi
économie circulaire qui finalement après
des débats parfois houleux sont votés à
l'unanimité
du coup muriel pénicaud dit on va faire
un accompagnement psychologique une
prise en charge des frais d'obsèques
l'ouvrir aux fonctionnaires est-ce que
vous tombez pas dans l'excès inverse du
coup en tout cas je pense qu'on a
réalisé qu'on n'était pas on était on ne
répondait pas à l'attendre des français
et que la position qu'on avait ne
pouvait pas être la position définitive
donc maintenant on va chercher la bonne
position de sortie à la fois sur les
douze jours tant qu'à fin autant traiter
aussi la question des fonctionnaires ça
paraît légitime et le grand événement et
même des indépendants et éventuellement
de voir le reste finalement on ouvre un
sujet qui est un sujet de société qui
est plus global qui est l'accompagnement
de ceux qui vivent ce qui est
probablement la chose la plus dramatique
à vivre la paire de neufs jours c'est
suffisant quand c'est des drames inquiet
car maintenant on en rediscutera du
l'occasion de rediscuter au fond on
oublie
que vous êtes secrétaire d'état sans
émissions énergétiques et c'est là
dessus qu'on va vous poser des questions
notamment à propos du coût d'électricité
effectivement la hausse des tarifs de
l'électricité puisque 4% en janvier +2
4% en février
contrairement à l'an dernier où les
tarifs avaient été gelés à cause de la
crise des gilets jaunes est ce que ce
n'est pas le pouvoir d'achat qui va en
prendre un coup
l'année dernière on a fait geler les
hausses de tarifs mais du coup elles ont
eu lieu plus tôt au moment au début de
l'été et il faut finir de les étaler et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il hausse
en janvier de nouveau une hausse en
février
mais c'est dur on est je reconnais que
c'est dur on est aussi à un moment où on
a une baisse des tarifs réglementés du
gaz alors c'est pas la même énergie ce
n'est pas toujours exactement les mêmes
foyers mêler les deux énergies n'évolue
pas dans le même sens mais surtout on
est prêt maintenant sous l'égide
d'elisabeth borgne a vraiment porté une
vision de la réforme de la tarification
de l'électricité et notamment de la
manière dont edf vend à ses concurrents
pour ne pas se retrouver tous les ans
confronté à 7,87 de cela puisque dans le
même temps on voit qu edf est obligé de
vendre moins cher à ses concurrents pour
qu'ensuite ses concurrents vont moins
cher qu edf pour tout cela pour ouvrir
ce marché
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas tout
simplement en train de tuer edf donc je
crois pas je crois qu'au contraire on
est en train d'essayer de trouver le bon
positionnement d'edf qui exploite le
parc historique notamment le parc
nucléaire qui doit pouvoir bénéficier
non seulement aux abonnés d'edf mais
finalement à tous les français parce que
ça a été un investissement collectif
d'une entreprise publique et donc on
cherche la bonne manière de faire pour
que cette électricité vendue à son coût
de revient qui est relativement bas par
rapport au coût actuel de l'électricité
puissent profiter à tous ceux ci dans un
équilibre gueuse quand même votre
histoire
tout est toujours compliqué d'en imputer
logis devient de volley messieurs ce
qu'est l'usiné edf vendra quand même
plus cher que ses concurrents dans le
nouveau système
edf mettra sur le marché de
l'électricité nucléaire au coût de
revient et après le 2e des f
distributeurs donc vis-à-vis de ses
clients rachètera au prix du marché
comme les autres opérateurs et donc au
contraire on aura un système dans lequel
on met à disposition de tout le monde
l'électricité nucléaire à un prix qui
est finalement assez modeste et après ce
sont tous les concurrents et du coup ce
sera plus neutres pour les français de
savoir à quel opérateur il s'adresse
pour qu'ils puissent choisir le kit
kiesler opérateurs d'autres
augmentations sont prévues en mars avril
mai juin d'autres augmentations ne sont
pas prévues en mars avril mai juin
alors on avait eu les coupures
d'électricité sauvage on se rappelle
bien sûr ses opérations avec la cgt
énergie maintenant elle déconnecte les
compteurs ans a été le cas en lorraine
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
opérations qui sont des opérations
d'électricité gratuite
là pour le coup c'est populaire combien
ça va coûter à l'état moi je suis
évidemment très hostile à toutes les
opérations dans lesquelles il y avait
des coupures de courant qui d'ailleurs
ont été assez dramatiques dans pas mal
de cas des cliniques des services de
secours ou des entreprises qui en défaut
d'alimentation ont perdu leurs stocks
mais globalement moi je suis défavorable
aux actions dans lesquelles les salariés
décident de ce qu'on fait avec
l'électricité soit en la coupant soit en
la distribuant gratuitement droit de
grève est un droit constitutionnel
respecté mais ça veut pas dire le droit
de maîtriser l'outil de production et
d'en faire ce qu'on veut et de décider
qui va avoir accès à l'électricité
gratuite où ça coûte cher on l'a pas
chiffré à ce stade mais en tout cas sur
le principe je peux pas y être favorable
pour les empêcher
parce qu'en ce qui concerne les coupures
on a essayé de rétablir le plus vite
possible
là encore je verse ça n'est pas
forcément un grand nombre de salariés
qui mettent en place des opérations mais
ces opérations peut pas les laisser
tranquillement oui les électriciens et
gaziers ont aujourd'hui un régime de
retraite qu'on dit spécial est-ce qu'ils
auront demain un régime spécifique
l'objectif de la réforme des retraites
c'est bien d'aller vers l'universalité
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le début et
c'est bien la volonté du gouvernement
leur évite n'y a pas deux mais il ya le
fait que la discussion a lieu branche
par branche avec chacune des branches
qui aujourd'hui est dans un régime
spécial est là encore elle a eu lieu
avec la ministre elisabeth bornes plus
tôt pour discuter des modalités de
transition et plus tôt pour discuter de
la manière dont on va appliquer la
pénibilité puisque la contrepartie de 10
on va un régime universel c'est de dire
tous les métiers pénibles
certains étaient reconnus dans des
régimes spéciaux d'autre part vont être
reconnus pour ce qu'ils sont pour
permettre des dispositifs type carrières
longues ou départs anticipés partir un
peu plus tôt à la confession de la
reconnaissance de la paix de l'unité
encore le roi des rois le statut qui
sera le fait générateur qui skie mais on
travaille le plancher d'un régime
spécial pour les électriciens et gaziers
non les gens qui ont des métiers
pénibles qui travaillent en trois-huit
qui travaillent la nuit tous ses
salariés là qu'ils soient aujourd'hui
dans un régime spécial où qu'il soit
simplement dans un régime classique de
droit privé il faut reconnaître que
c'est plus dur que c'est plus usant et
qu' il faut pouvoir partir plus tôt en
revanche les salariés d ing qui sont
dans cette situation là ont vocation à
rentrer dans le régime de pénibilité
mais ce n'est pas la re création d'un
régime s'est en revanche sur le
calendrier de mise en place de la
réforme pour les électriciens et les
gaziers ce sera le même calendrier que
tout le monde ou est ce que il y aura
des étalements comme ça sera le cas par
exemple originaux pour les régimes
spéciaux on a proposé aux organisations
syndicales de rentrer dans une
discussion sur l'étalement la date
d'entrée en vigueur donc on est
potentiellement sur des dates
différentes en fonction des entreprises
et des situations mais ça rentre dans la
discussion syndicat table alors on va
parler de la centrale de fessenheim
puisqu'on parle d'énergie
l'asn l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
alerte et demande à edf de produire un
dossier technique précis pour la
fermeture de fessenheim est ce que ça
veut dire qu'on ne maîtrise rien ni sur
la technologie ni sur le calendrier pour
savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut fermer
sept centrales cette fermeture tellement
promise est ce que c'est un saut dans le
vide
non ça veut pas dire ça heureusement la
fermeture de fessenheim
elle avait été promise à de nombreuses
reprises c'est un engagement que le
président de la république avait repris
dans sa campagne
ça fait partie des engagements que nous
tenons puisque nous allons vraiment
fermer la centrale électrique de
fessenheim en fermant le premier
réacteur en février prochain et le
deuxième en juin au moment où on arrête
de produire de l'électricité à
fessenheim on démarre les opérations de
démantèlement qui elles ne sont pas
pressés qu'ils vont prendre du temps sur
le site edf a fait un premier dossier
qui présente les opérations de
démantèlement c'est d'ailleurs aussi la
première fois qu'on se lance dans une
opération de démantèlement de ce type la
scène dit il faut compléter le dossier
je pense qu'elle est totalement dans son
rose ou les banques
j'en sais rien parce que ça c'est
vraiment le dossier de technique de
l'asn qui l'a rendu public aujourd'hui
c'est une discussion entre l'autorité de
sûreté qui est une autorité indépendante
qui garantit la sûreté des installations
nucléaires et l'exploitant mais ce que
je peux dire c'est que ce démantèlement
prendra le temps nécessaire qu on a pas
d'urgence particulière et que bien
évidemment il sera fait dans des
conditions que l'asn juge satisfaisante
et si edf doit compléter son dossier edf
complétera sont les cyrillois retard du
calendrier fait un retard dans le
calendrier
non c'est pas une question de retard de
calendrier avec les embryons non parce
que ce sont deux étapes différentes
d'arrêter de produire et de démanteler
d'accord les uns se porte juste pour
finir sur fessenheim parce que c'est
vraiment un point très important c'est
pas une décision facile cette décision
notamment pour les élus pour les
salariés moi je pense aux salariés sur
le site de fessenheim je pense aux sous
traitants et donc cette décision elle
doit s'accompagner d'un projet de
territoire d'une capacité à retrouver de
l'activité économique
et c'est tout le travail qu'on fait
depuis deux ans donc la fermeture de
fessenheim elle a un côté technique sous
la responsabilité de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire et bien sûr que ce sera
fait dans les règles et elle a aussi un
côté revitalisation développement
économique passage à des énergies
renouvelables sur le site sur lequel il
ya encore beaucoup de travail je
voudrais rassurer les élus locaux et les
salariés pour dire qu'on ne lâchera pas
cette partie là on me dit c'est la
première fois qu'on démantèle
effectivement une centrale nucléaire
vous connaissez l'impact écologique que
ça va avoir l'impact écologique d'abord
on va arrêter d'utiliser des produits
nucléaires qui ensuite fonds d'aidé qui
ont des déchets nucléaires de haute
intensité donc l'impact écologique
il est globalement positif dans la
mesure où l'une des questions posées par
l'énergie nucléaire
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles on
veut passer de 72 % à 50% de nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique sait aussi que
la question de la longue vie des déchets
à haute intensité n'est pas vraiment
réglé après il ya d'autres pays dans le
monde
qui ont arrêté des centrales nucléaires
on a la capacité à le faire à retraités
à démanteler et donc il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude particulière mais une
vigilance forte c'est ce que là et cela
nous dit logique sur des années quand
même mais l'impact écologique mon là en
ayant des sites progressivement en
fermant ces sites on va aussi revenir à
des énergies plus renouvelable un
tableau logique plus faible pour l'heure
la france compte encore 58 réacteurs
nucléaires en fonctionnement répartis
dans 19 centrales un certain nombre de
problèmes de sécurité ont été identifiés
notamment chez les sous traitants
le président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire appelle justement un
ressaisissement est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des failles dans la sécurité
nucléaire en france
je pense qu'on a un système de
surveillance en france qui est très
exigeant et c'est très bien ainsi
donc c'est très bien que l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire appelle à la vigilance
pointe les sujets sur lesquels il faut
que l'exploitant soit particulièrement
attentifs après il n'y a pas de danger
et l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire n'a
pas pointé deux sujets qui nécessiterait
une action en urgence c'est plutôt un
appel général au moment où on va on
espère avant la mise en service du
réacteur de flamanville le père au
moment où on démarre le démantèlement de
ferraille attendre au moment où l'on
travaille sur le site d'enfouissement de
bure
c'est important de redire à la filière
qu'elle doit respecter toutes les normes
de sécurité et aussi retrouvé de la
compétence
vous savez qu'on travaille avec bruno le
maire dans le comité stratégique de
filière a continué à garder des
compétences qui nous permettront d'être
efficace sur la filière nucléaire y
compris dans les fermetures dans le
démantèlement et dans l'accompagnement
global de 7 juillet emmanuel macron est
en pologne
aujourd'hui il a dit vouloir aider la
pologne à relever le défi climatique en
développant la coopération dans le
domaine de l'énergie ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que l'on va vendre du
nucléaire
à la pologne on a besoin de la pologne
pour avancer en europe sur la transition
énergétique et écologique
vous savez que nous souhaitons que
l'union européenne se donne un objectif
de neutralité carbone en 2050 et qu'on
se donne un objectif ambitieux de
réduction de nos émissions carbone entre
50 et 55 % en 2030 et la pologne fait
partie des états qui disent on n'est pas
contre l'objectif
en général on trouve ça très bien mais
on pense qu'on n'est pas capable
notamment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
chars de la charge beaucoup de centrales
à charge aux caisses qu'elles sont
remplacés donc froid et radiculaire
française l'idée c'est d'accompagner la
pologne dans sa transition énergétique
officiel le souhaitent
après il n'ya pas que le nucléaire ou le
charbon nous on est parti dans un
développement fort des énergies
renouvelables à projets on propose à la
pologne
on va savoir aux jeunes pour la pologne
à la place de la pologne
on dit juste à ce stade à la pologne
c'est important que vous soyez à bord
comme le reste des états de l'union
européenne dans cette ambition d'aller
vers une énergie plus propre une
électricité plus propre on est prêt à
travailler avec vous surtout le mix
énergétique pour trouver un mix
énergétique qui vous permettent
d'accélérer la sortie du chardon en
france nous on ferme les quatre
dernières centrales électriques à
charbon là aussi c'est difficile
il y en a une à gardanne il y en a une
en moselle à saint-avold
voilà donc au bout du rouleau partager
l'expérience dans ce qui est facile et
dans ce qui est difficile avec nous il
faut le remplacer par quelque chose
quand même
en france on le remplace par des
énergies renouvelables ser le rte en
pologne encore une fois je fais pas le
mix énergétique de la pologne à la place
de la zone passe directement du charbon
aux énergies mais on peut y passer
progressivement vous savez l'allemagne
notre arme nucléaire
l'allemagne à fermer ses centrales
nucléaires d'abord plutôt déployer du
charbon est maintenant ferme
progressivement le charbon au profit des
renouvelables donc c'est possible
d'avoir un mix dans lequel il ya -
nucléaire - de charbon est plus dure un
peu tout la dernière question qui ne
porte pas sur l'énergie vendredi dernier
le conseil constitutionnel a dit qu'on
ne pouvait pas vendre à l'étranger des
pesticides dont l'usagé est interdit en
france dans l'union européenne
quand est ce que les industriels
français vont devoir s'arrêter il ya
deux dates en 2022 prévoyait le projet
de loi et galim et puis 2020
disait le projet de loi pacte ou est-ce
qu'on en est quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter
mais d'abord je voudrais saluer cette
décision du conseil constitutionnel
parce que au-delà du cas d'espèce j'y
reviens le conseil constitutionnel a
réaffirmé ou infirmer un principe
écologique très fort qui s'applique à
nos textes qui je crois est bien dans
l'esprit de ce que le président du
conseil constitutionnel laurent fabius a
apporté
lorsqu'il a présidé la coop en france la
coop 21 et donc je pense que c'est
important que le conseil constitutionnel
reconnaît ce que l'écologie est un
principe à part entière dans notre
constitution et peuvent à nouveau les
intérêts économiques ça a été écrit
comme ça
les cycles vous demande après je n'ai
pas la réponse à la date précise puisque
la décision est récente le gouvernement
évidemment va en tirer les conséquences
et refaire un calendrier mais plus
possible quoi nous sommes le 3 février
et il fait 27 degrés dans le sud ouest
de la france
est-ce qu'on a perdu la bataille du
climat alors on sait que le
réchauffement climatique existe que les
scientifiques nous le disent tout le
temps
le réchauffement climatique c'est
l'augmentation de la température moyenne
s'est pas exactement la même chose que
les pics de chaleur ou des règlements
clymène mais on a vécu dans les vingt
dernières années entre 2000 et 2010 19
15 des années les plus chaudes donc on
voit bien que ça s'accélère et donc oui
notre combat c'est un combat pour faire
face à l'urgence mais fait non c'est pas
trop tard moi j'aimerais passer au moins
un message là dessus qui s est pas trop
tard parce que ça a déjà commencé
ça a commencé sur l'énergie on en
parlait on a déjà à peu près 15 %
d'énergies renouvelables dans notre
électricité on va passer à 30
ça a commencé sur les transports avec
des normes beaucoup plus forte sur les
voitures
ça a commencé sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments là on est en
train de simplifier d'améliorer toutes
les aides ça commence sur à peu près
tous les compartiments de la transition
écologique donc ce n'est rien mais ça ne
s'est pas perdue il faut aller le plus
vite possible et le plus loin possible
et ensemble c'est vraiment ça maintenant
notre enjeu ensemble à l'échelle à merci
a lancé à l'échelle internationale bonne
chance merci
brigitte merci dame et à lundi prochain
bien évidemment merci beaucoup
on va accueillir maintenant les deux
parlementaires qui attend là en
coulisses qui ont leurs questions à eux
merci beaucoup de parlementaires le
temps qui s'installe je vous posais une
question de téléspectateurs qui nous est
arrivé là est-ce que vous soutenez greta
une berck dans sa croisade écologistes
citoyens payeurs qui disent assure
philippe alary faire un rapide je
soutiens great attenberg dans son rôle
de lanceuse d' alerte parce que je pense
qu'elle incarne vraiment la voix de la
jeunesse et que les jeunes se
reconnaissent en elle et du coup je vous
avoue que je ne supporte pas le mépris
les insultes la condescendance vis-à-vis
de great attenberg après je la trouve
excessive dans ses messages dans sa
condamnation quand tu es à longueur de
discours elle dit aux adultes présents
dans la salle vous n'avez rien fait
parce que ça rebondit sur la
conversation qu'on venait d'avoir en
réalité la transformation écologique
elle a déjà commencé et elle s'adresse à
ceux qui sont vraiment en train
d'essayer d'accélérer
donc je j'aimerais bien qu'elle soit un
petit peu plus dans les solutions et pas
uniquement dans l'interpellation du
message ça me regarde pas ce soir
bonsoir idiart vous êtes député les
républicains des bouches-du-rhône et
bonsoir et au compteur vous êtes-vous
sénateurs écologistes et de l'isère on
va commencer par vous eric diard parce
que vous voulez poser une question sur
un chantier qui est en cours c'est la
consultation citoyenne sur
l'environnement oui madame la ministre
je voulais vous parler un peu de cette
consultation citoyenne sur
l'environnement alors nous moi je fais
partie de la commission des lois
nous avons auditionné les membres nous
avons auditionné la co présidente madame
tubes y en a 150 de ces personnes
planchent actuellement jusqu'au mois
d'avril
on a vu un petit peu différents sujets
c'est ça ressemble un petit peu un grand
baie brainstorming mais je partage un
peu l'avis de la cour présidente qui l'a
dit en commission des lois
c'est bien on fait travailler les
citoyennes parti mais que va-t-il
advenir même la coprésidente a des
doutes sur l'issue de cette consultation
citoyenne fois la question et la réponse
alors ce qu'on souhaite c'est que ces
150 citoyens aboutissent à des
propositions suffisamment concrètes et
suffisamment détaillées pour qu'on
puisse les mettre en oeuvre
si ces propositions sont législatives
nous avons dit depuis le début
elles seront soit soumise au parlement
dans un texte de loi voire propose un
référendum en fonction du contenu de ces
propositions pour que ça fonctionne il
faut que ces propositions soient
suffisamment concrètes et précises parce
que là on est à mi chemin la prochaine
session a lieu là dans quelques jours et
sur certains sujets
les propositions intermedia ce ne sont
que des propositions intermédiaires sont
encore très général je prends un exemple
sur la partie se nourrir qui est une
partie importante pour la convention et
propositions sont vraiment utiliser la
politique agricole commune et sa réforme
pour accélérer la transition agricole et
ça je pense qu'on est tous d'accord mais
on est à un niveau de généralité qui est
quand même assez élevé et donc ça c'est
pas une proposition législative mais je
pense qu'il y ait ça peut pas être
retenu comme c'est pas ça c'est que on
est encore à un niveau trouva qui
ressemble plus à une intention se trouve
à une orientation cas une proposition
concrète sur laquelle on peut décider
oui ou non ça devient un texte de loi
donc le président de la république est
allé les voir vous l'avez probablement
vu lors de la dernière séance et leur a
dit je me suis engagé à transmettre sans
filtre au parlement ou au référendum
mais je ne peux transmettre que des
choses qui sont suffisamment précises
est prête et il s'est engagé à revenir
vers les citoyens les 150 en rendant
compte de ce qu'il fera des différentes
sessions session ce qu'il y aura dedans
oui je mange sur cette question la
réponse est satisfait mais c'est vrai
que j'ai eu des propositions qui
manquait un petit peu d'encre et je sais
pas il y avait des choses c'était un
brave un basque brainstorming ce qui
leur passait dans la tête on fait ça je
vous avais du mal à voir certaines
choses comment allait se concrétiser
quoi on peut perdre ceux des prochaines
sessions il reste une session février
une en mars une en avril est donc
l'enjeu des faits trois sessions c'est
que les propositions des contres d'une
certaine manière jusqu'à devenir
opérationnel est peut-être moins
nombreuses que le résultat du
brainstorming guillaume médiateur
voulait interroger la ministre emmanuel
vergoz sur les contrats de transition
écologique avec les territoires
ce sont des contrats signés entre l'état
et certains territoires pour faire la
transition écologique je re situer un
petit peu c'est ça ben en fait on
parlait justement je pense qu'on a
besoin de concret d'action et c'est vrai
qu'à travers les territoires moi je suis
persuadé que la transition écologique à
se mettre en place à travers les
territoires au niveau des communes des
intercommunalités des métropoles et
d'ailleurs on a transféré beaucoup de
compétence là dessus on a eu les
territoires à énergie positive avec
justement un financement derrière la
gare par exemple pour les pour
construire des habitations
moi c'est ça il ya des plateformes de
rénovation plateforme de rénovation
thermique autour de l'énergie aussi avec
des centrales villageoise fin ont eu un
certain nombre de changements que ce
sont bien les trios dévoila choses très
concrètes sur sur la transition
écologique et bon gouvernement
souhaitait tirer un trait sur ce sur ce
qui avait déjà été fait pour repartir
sur des contrats de transition
écologique pour qu'on ait un peu plus de
60 qui ont été pointés signé moi ce qui
me perturbe un petit peu c'est que ces
excès contrat on a zéro financement
c'est à dire que en fait c'est un
redéploiement des financements existants
c'est un redéploiement de l'ingénierie
existantes mais on n'a rien en plus qui
est un petit peu il n'ya pas d'habitude
un vrai qu'avec ce gouvernement et moi
du coup j'avais une question on a des
financements on à la taxe carbone qui
fait qui fait beaucoup débat mais qui
existent encore et est ce que vous êtes
d'accord à un moment donné pour dire
fléchon une partie de cette de cette
taxe carbone de cette contribution
climat énergie vers les territoires
concrètement pour qu'ils puissent
s'emparer et moi je pense qu'il faut
faire confiance aux territoires pour
mettre en place cette transition et
alors la réponse
plusieurs éléments de réponse d'abord
sur les dispositifs précédents on les
termine c'est à dire qu'on accompagne
tous les territoires pour lesquels
l'investissement était promis mais pas
encore fait et donc toutes les promesses
de financement de la période précédente
seront honorés alors même que c'était
pas complètement budgété les contrats de
transition écologique
on travaille dans l'autre sens dans
l'autre sens c'est à dire au lieu
d'avoir une enveloppe et de la répartir
entre des territoires ont dit en fait on
va mobiliser les financements existants
de l'état alors vous pouvez dire c'est
du redéploiement mais en réalité ce sont
des financements qui sont pas toujours
utilisés ou qui sont pas toujours
vraiment orienté sur ces sujets on a 80
territoires qui sont rentrés dans cette
logique de contrats de transition
écologique j'étais à nevers aujourd'hui
pour en signer un le plus petit doigt
faire quinze mille habitants le plus
gros doit faire 300 350 mille habitants
on couvre presque 10 millions de
français
on va investir 1,2 milliard d'euros dans
ses contrats donc ça commence à devenir
très significatif 1,2 milliard d'euros
c'est pas 1,2 milliard d'euros de l'état
la part état sur ces contrats c'est
entre 10 et 40 % ça dépend du contrat
le reste sont des collectivités
territoriales ce sont des investisseurs
privés beaucoup
et donc ce sont ces différents acteurs
qui se mettent d'accord mais franchement
pour y passer beaucoup de temps je crois
que suis allé dans 30 territoires qui
sont en train de signer un contrat de
transition écologique
ils me disent tous pour une fois vous ne
vous ne nous imposez pas un modèle duo
c'est pas normés on travaille à partir
de ce que nous souhaitons faire nous je
crois que c'est une des valeurs ajoutées
de ce dispositif
on entend effectivement ces choses là
mais on entend aussi que pour mettre en
place ces différentes mesures afin
mettre en place ces trois écologies qu
on a quand même besoin de moyens et que
c'est vrai que pour l'instant la taxe
carbone qui finance une partie notamment
du cic eux
je ne sais pas si c'est la priorité on
parlait d' attenberg de données je sais
plus combien à combien on et 750
millions d'euros à carrefour
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas réorienter un
petit peu
un petit peu d'argent justement sur
cette transition écologique et
directement sur les territoires
rapidement et d'abord sur les projets
sur les projets des contrats de
transition écologique moi je n'ai vu
aucun projet aujourd'hui mur sur un
territoire sur lequel on n'arrive pas à
faire le tour de table
en réalité l'argent suit les projets
après oui une question plus globale de
savoir comment on oriente l'argent du
budget de l'état entre des
investissements favorables à l'écologie
et des investissements qui vont pas dans
le bon sens et je vous rejoins sur ce
point on est en train de faire une revue
des différents grands dispositifs de
financement de l'état sur est-ce qu'ils
sont ouverts ou pas vert et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille au bout de cette
logique y compris aussi en trouvant la
complémentarité entre l'argent de l'état
l'argent européen notamment l'avait
encore au clair avec 106 yeux pour le
mettre dans l'économie en fait la
question c'est pas telle ou disent que
vous disais la question pour moi ça
n'est pas le fléchage du cic de la taxe
carbone c'est on prend le budget de
l'état on regarde si les investissements
sur l'écologie sont suffisants on va
chercher l'argent européen notamment la
b si les probabilités en a
éventuellement chercher aussi de
l'investissement privé parce qu'un mot
quand on a besoin d'investir priver un
citoyen sur à quoi sert cette taxe
carbone à l'offre et ça c'est important
et ça c'est autre chose et on va parler
d'abord du nucléaire parce que tous les
deux vous voulez parler du nucléaire
c'est ce que vous m'avez dit sauf que
pas forcément de la même façon en tout
cas rien à envie de vous en parler
moi je voulais vous parler du nucléaire
bon première membres je suis attaché au
mix énergétique
je pense que premièrement nous devons
développer nous faisons les énergies
renouvelables mais nous ne vont pas
abandonner notre parc nucléaire et nous
devons engager de gros investissements
parce que le parc nucléaire vieilli et
je pense qu'il ya aussi une possibilité
de vendre notre électricité à l'étranger
prendre qu'un exemple 645 millions
d'africains vivent sans électricité et
la croissance démographique fait que ça
va s'accélérer donc il ya un potentiel
marché et donc je suis je défend
fermement le nucléaire et les
les énergies renouvelables et moi je
voulais poser une question à la ministre
un petit peu rapidement sur ce projet
hercules edf avec cette scission edf
distributeurs d'énergie et edf
producteur d'énergie qui inquiète
est-ce qu'on va vers une privatisation
d'une partie et est ce qu'on va pas
continuer à augmenter les tarifs
j'ai peut-être répondre d'abord sur la
place du nucléaire nous la position que
nous avons pris c'est ce qu'il y a dans
le grand document de programmation qui
s'appelle la programmation pluriannuelle
de l'énergie c'est 50 % de notre
électricité d'origine nucléaire en 2035
sachant qu'aujourd'hui on est à 72 %
donc ça veut dire moins de nucléaire on
s'est pas prononcé sur la poursuite
après 2035
il faut regarder différents scénarii un
scénario dans lequel on garde du
nucléaire un scénario dans lequel on
peut aller à 100% d'énergies
renouvelables et la discussion pour
savoir s'il faut investir dans du
nouveau nucléaire c'est une discussion
que nous aurons dans deux trois ans
alors c'est parce qu'elle n'est pas mûre
l'autre aspect de la question c'est edf
coupée en deux le réseau distribution et
la commercialisation est ce que il faut
craindre une privatisation non la
crainte de privatisation n'est pas
l'idée c'est plutôt de de clarifier à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise d'edf ce qui
est de l'exploitation finalement de
notre bien commun c'est à dire le parc
existant et c'est ce dont on parlait il
ya quelques minutes le fait de pouvoir
mettre sur le marché en respectant des
conditions de concurrence l'électricité
issue de ce parc existant de séparer
cette activité-là de l'activité
distribution qui a vocation à trèves une
activité concurrentielle pourquoi
coupure mais ça va rester une seule
entreprise
et puis edf est aussi présent sur le
marché des énergies renouvelables jc
réseau de l'entreprise
le travail est en cours pour regarder
les différentes hypothèses les décisions
sont pas complètement prise sur non plus
donc
le gouvernement n'a pas encore fait
d'annoncé sur ce sujet donc c'est un peu
prématuré d'en parler mais le travail se
fait en ce groupe c'est pas sûr que ça
se fasse
ah si ça se fait en ce sens je le
travail se fait donc temps que les
décisions sont pas prises définitivement
et annoncées elles sont en cours
d'instruction et fonctionnellement
essentielle en cours d'instruction tout
dans le sens d'une scission de des
efforts de guillaume gontard vous voulez
parler aussi de
du nucléaire mais parce que il ya des
problèmes de sécurité dites-vous liées à
l'eau oui plus plus globalement c'est à
dire que c'est avec le nucléaire on dit
souvent c'est une énergie décarbonée bon
elle n'est pas elle n'est pas de toute
façon complètement parce que je connais
pas d'énergie qu'il soit complètement
qu'ils soient complètement décarbonée
par contre elle est très grosses
consommatrices très grosse consommatrice
en eau puisque je crois que la moitié de
l'eau consommée en france les pôles
nucléaire pour l'heureux le
refroidissement qu'on a vu qu'il ya eu
des réacteurs qui avait été arrêté cet
été justement pour ces épreuves donc on
a toutes un une problématique de
sécurité liées à l'eau et que souvent en
amont on à l'hydroélectricité les
barrages qui moi me semble quelque chose
de particulièrement stratégique à la
fois pour la sécurité nucléaire et puis
parce que toi bien le jour sur la
biodiversité etc et que justement dans
ce projet les reculs on parle beaucoup
et on a beaucoup parlé de l'ouverture à
la concurrence des barrages de 150
barrages sur le territoire français qui
moi m'inquiète beaucoup en
particulièrement sur sur mon territoire
qu'on entend beaucoup de choses donc là
sur le projet recul de temps en temps on
nous dit que le ca sera regroupé entre
le nucléaire et l'hydroélectricité est
ce que ça vous pouvez nous nous le
confirmer en tout cas est-ce que vous
quelle est votre position par rapport à
cette place de l'hydroélectricité est ce
que vous souhaitez comme moi je pense
que ce cet élément stratégique reste
sous le giron de l'état et que nos biens
communs bien sûr qu'on conduit à son
garde la main sur nos biens d'abord sur
l'énergie sur l'électricité mais même
sur l'énergie
notre premier objectif c'est la
réduction de consommation n'en a pas
parlé mais avant de savoir comment on
produit ce qu'on consomme la meilleure
chose à faire pour la planète et pour
nos concitoyens et d'ailleurs pour le
portefeuille
c'est d'aller vers des économies
d'énergie une fois qu'on a dit ça on va
quand même avoir besoin d'énergie et
donc nous notre position c'est d'avoir
un mix plus ouvert plus équilibré parce
que moi je vais vous suivre quand vous
dites que chaque source d'énergie a ses
avantages et ses inconvénients
le nucléaire moi je vous ai parlé des
déchets parce que c'est quand même une
vraie question de savoir ce qu'on fait
des matériaux en fin de vie il ya aussi
la question du refroidissement des
centrales vous avez raison cet été on a
eu 86 départements en alerte sécheresse
et on a eu
des inquiétudes pour un certain nombre
de centrales sur leur capacité à
continuer à fonctionner pas d inquiétude
de sécurité du tout les arêtes des
inquiétudes de capacité à fonctionner
compte tenu du fait que un certain
nombre de fleuves et des rivières
notamment la loire et basse donc on voit
bien que on a absolument besoin de
diversifier alors c'est notre mix
énergétique deuxième aspect des
conditions allaient participer ben oui
ça fait pas d'abord c'est notre première
source d'électricité renouvelable en
france on a pris de l'avancé on a la
chance d'avoir des cours d'eau qui ont
été équipés et c'est une source
d'énergie renouvelable vraiment
intéressante
donc ça fait des années et on a repris
ce flambeau qu'on discute avec la
commission européenne on va le faire
avec la nouvelle commission pour
rediscuter de la question de l'ouverture
à la concurrence pour être en capacité
de garder la valeur que sont nos
barrages qui répondent à la fois des
besoins énergétiques mais aussi à
l'ordre et à des bleus a composé de
simples ayant la rage devrait rester
quand même à majorité capitaux d'état en
gros ce que je dis c'est que quand on
regarde ce que fait un barrage
d'hydroélectricité certes ça produit de
l'électricité mais ça ça aide aussi à la
régulation du cycle de l'eau dans un
certain nombre de cas c'est aussi un
élément d'aménagement du territoire
parce qu'on a des bases de tourisme qui
se sont installées sur les lacs et donc
quand on parle d'ouverture à la
concurrence il faut regarder tous les
services rendus et pas seulement le prix
du kilowattheure donc on voudrait
discuter avec l'union européenne de
savoir dans quelles conditions on n'est
pas totalement satisfait de la manière
dont l'union européenne voudrait ouvrir
à la concurrence et ça fait partie des
discussions qui sont en cours et ce sera
ouvert à la concurrence quand même en
fonction des discussions qui auront lieu
on va respecter le droit communautaire
mais on souhaite la ménager un peu à mot
à mot juste avant même que vous dites
que du coup on ira quand même vers
l'ouverture à la concurrence qu'on soit
bien bien clair on a tout à fait les
possibilités la france a tout à fait les
possibilités en déclarant juste
d'intérêt général la production
d'électricité par les barrages de sortir
de ces dispositions européennes
et d'affirmer que c'est l'état qui gère
ces barrages donc c'est assez du coup un
vrai choix politique et je suis pas sûr
que vous fassiez le bon choix alors pour
l'instant on en est encore au stade
discute avec la commission européenne à
un moment je suis d'accord avec vous
faudra se positionner on n'y est pas
encore tout à fait mais en tout cas on
veut pas aller bille en tête dans
l'ouverture débrider la ministre un
petit regret vous avez parlé de la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
c'est à la baisse le manque d'ambition
sur la méthanisation qui est passé de 10
à 7 % je le regrette parce que je pense
que c'est une énergie qui est justement
on peu consommatrices de co2 en fait
cette programmation pluriannuelle on l'a
mise en consultation première
consultation il ya un an c'est un
document qui prend du temps à être
adoptée et parmi les grands changements
qu'on a fait entre il ya un an et
aujourd'hui on a remis 2 milliards
d'euros sur la méthanisation
on était à 7,9 milliards on est
maintenant à presque 10 milliards dans
la programmation
justement parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que l'ambition était insuffisante sur la
méthanisation vous avez en face de vous
aussi des élus locaux eric diard vous et
élus des bouches du rhône
et vous vous avez chez vous lâche entre
la centrale à charbon de gardanne qui va
fermer dans deux ans et vous aviez des
questions à poser à la ministre oui
madame le ministre parce que vous êtes
venu l'année vous vous êtes venu la
semaine dernière
ça fait partie des quatre sites qui doit
fermer en 2022
mais s'il ya un plan de conversion des
solutions pour les trois autres sites à
ce jour jeudi à ce jour il n'y a pas de
plan il ya eu des piliers des
propositions des syndicats des
propositions des élus locaux des
propositions des associations
vous avez dit ça sera prêt pour cet été
mais pourquoi ce retard à l'allumage
pour cette centrale est pas pour les
nous at on dit quoi comme j'attends que
sont l'emploi je suis sur l'emploi sur
la reconversion ce qui s'est fait sur
les autres centrales celle là il ya un
retard à l'allumage
en fait moi j'ai envie de vous retourner
la question parce que la raison pour
laquelle on est moins avancée à gardanne
que dans les trois autres sites
c'est parce que les élus locaux tout
tout tout et tous les élus que ce soit
les maires la métropole et le
département et la région se sont pas
complètement emparé du sujet et n'ont
pas vraiment travailler à un projet de
territoire et moi je salue les deux mr
le maire de gardanne et le maire de
meyreuil qui en novembre on dit bon il
faut quand même qu'on s'y remette et qui
ont commencé à écrire un document qui
est un document d'orientation sur les
quelques axes de développement mais les
projets de territoire
ça se fait pas depuis paris ça se fait
pas uniquement avec l'état les syndicats
sont dans un conflit dur sur le site moi
j'ai reçu la cgt vous savez la cgt
manifestaient devant la préfecture la
manifestation habituelle du bruit etc
j'ai dit ok moi je souhaite les voir
donc j'ai reçu une délégation et à titre
d' apaisement j'ai accepté que l'état
finance à 100 % une étude que les
organisations syndicales et la cgt veut
faire parce que l'entreprise devait la
finance et met un peu de temps à la jv
qui assure le relais c'est l'assurance
de tous les scénarii l'étude pour
réfléchir aux possibilités industriel du
site
on est debout traitement des salariés de
tous et du coup de reclassement parce
que tout le monde on a deux questions
posées sur les sites des centrales à
charbon
comment on accompagne les personnes qui
sont frappés qui vont perdre leur emploi
c'est évidemment une question
extrêmement importante on a des gens on
a des familles et quel est l'avenir du
territoire
les deux sont quand même signé parce que
quand vous avez vous à les implanter une
nouvelle usine
dans ce cas là vous pouvez vous demander
comment vous accompagnez rebondir à
gardanne
on n'est pas suffisamment avancée aussi
parce que les syndicats portait un
projet d'incinérateur dont les élus ne
veulent pas et donc pour sortir de ce
blocage
on a on remet tout le monde autour de la
table mais il faut activer le siège de
rabaisser je renvoie encore l'aval à
madame la liste pour lui dire la
problématique vient aussi de du
millefeuille j'allais dire local où vous
avez parlé région vous avez parlé
département vous n'avez pas les communes
vous avez parlé métropole et que je vous
rajouterez conseil de territoire voyez
la problématique pour accorder tout ça
sur d'autres territoires on y arrive il
n'y a pas de raison qu'on n'y a rien que
je repose la question les salariés de
l'usiné de gardanne de la centrale de
charbon seront tous reclassés non je ne
sais pas répondre à cette question pour
l'instant on a une usine à gardanne qui
produit de l'électricité à partir de
biomasse là n'est pas mise en cause est
une unité qui produit à partir du
charbon
et ça va dépendre du projet de
développement du territoire constat voir
donc comment est ce qu'on peut proposer
des possibilités de reclassement aux
salariés mais le calendrier de la
fermeture dans deux ans il est malgré la
fermeture est toujours prévue d'ici à
2022 et puis par ailleurs on s'est
engagé à prendre une ordonnance spéciale
avec des mesures plus favorable de
reclassement qui est en cours de
discussion
guillaume gontard vouliez parler des
pesticides oui un petit un petit mot
puisqu'il ya un peu plus d'un an j'étais
ici à la même table et 7 et stéphane
travert qui était à votre à votre place
et vous avez expliqué que c'était pas la
peine de mettre notamment l'arrêt du
glyphosate dans la loi puisque c'était
une promesse présidentielle et que le
président tiendrait ses promesses et
tenait ses promesses
et là on vient d'apprendre quand on sait
que banon 7 pro mais cela ne saurait pas
tenu je pense que c'est enfin je sais
pas s'ils en tout cas vous vous pensez
que c'est une c'est une erreur une
erreur politique mais je pense qu'on a
besoin d'avancer sur ce sur ce sujet là
et qu'on peut pas avoir un renoncement
continuelle c'est la même manière sur
les perturbateurs endocriniens sur sur
l'ensemble sur l'ensemble des pesticides
et c'est vrai que encore une fois je
pense que cette question-là peut se
traiter à l'échelon des territoires sur
l'accompagnement de balles sur la
campagne porte la transition de la
transition agricole et comme on
accompagne les agriculteurs et donc est
ce que vous avez fait dans deux ans
justement pour accompagner cette
transition cette transition agricole et
qu'est ce que vous souhaitez faire
maintenant est ce qu'on souhaite faire
c'est sortir du glyphosate le plus vite
possible à 100 % à 100 %
la date de 2022 elle est difficile à
tenir on a des évaluations parlementaire
d'ailleurs qui nous disent que elle est
difficile à tenir ça dépend des filières
et au delà du glyphosate on souhaite
atteindre l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé
c'est moins réduction de 50% des
pesticides d'ici à 2025
quand on dit ça on voit qu'en fait c'est
une transformation complète de
l'agriculture qu'il faut qu'on
accompagne que ça se fait plutôt par
filière parce qu'en fait il ya d
agriculture différente qui ont des
usages différents
très concrètement par exemple on
accompagne ce qu'on appelle les fermes
dephy on a maintenant trois mille ferme
on veut monter à 10 milles qui teste des
pratiques dans lesquels on peut utiliser
beaucoup moins de pesticides pour moi la
question c'est la diffusion de ces
pratiques la diffusion des solutions
entre la recherche les fermes
expérimentales et puis tous les
agriculteurs dont toutes les
agricultures et là il faut qu'on aille
le plus vite possible mais après s'il
reste 5 % en 2022 on sera déjà content
d'avoir fait 95%
on va reverser et rivières et guillaume
gotthard est revenue sur ce plateau
merci d'avoir posé des questions et
emmanuelle wargon des questions très
précises et qui intéresse du monde parce
que par exemple l'ifo that c'est un sou
les français ainsi que gardanne parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont très
intéressés c'est très important dans le
sud de la france merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau et on va cueillir maintenant
yves thréard du figaro
bonsoir yves bonsoir francis blanche à
vous fassiez alors vous avez évoqué un
sujet tout à l'heure je m'exerçais un
petit droit de suite vous avez 10
février juin les deux réacteurs de
fessenheim vont fermer
très bien mais il reste encore deux ans
d'ici à la fin du quinquennat
combien de réacteurs après vont fermer
d'ici à la fin du quinquennat bah ça
vous avez la réponse dans le document de
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie mais mais du coup je vous
donne la réponse avec plaisir on a dit
qu'on allait fermer 12 réacteurs
supplémentaires d'ici à 2035 et les
fermetures sont positionnés plus tôt à
partir de 2025 2026 compte tenu du fait
qu'on a besoin d'avoir la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
pour pas fermé et importer de
l'électricité
et c'est bien la première fois qu'on
ferme et fessenheim ont fermé en 2020 ça
veut dire qu'on passerait de 73% à
combien 50
non non en fermant les deux réacteurs la
a franchement je ne sais pas répondre à
la question désolé c'est une colle bon
alors on a moins graves
c'est pas le jeu on vous en réforme des
retraites
on n'en a pas parlé ce soir c'est un
très beau très fort on a parlé un peu
pour les ivg les industries gazières un
peu un peu difficile à faire passer la
preuve
des centaines des milliers d'amendements
vous allez utiliser de 59,3 pour faire
passer cette réforme on est plutôt dans
l'ide 49,3 par le 49-3 pour les
téléspectateurs c'est une procédure
accélérée qui consiste à ne pas faire
voter les parlementaires c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour
après c'est sûr que vingt mille
amendements dans lesquelles ces dix neuf
mille fois le même amendement écrit un
tout petit peu différemment pour qu'on
n'ait pas discussions de paix
c'est pas très constructif non plus si
on veut discuter de la réforme au fond
et faire valoir ses arguments
donc nous on est prêts d'avoir une vraie
discussion parlementaire une
amélioration du texte dans la discussion
parlementaire 9,3 mais là en tout cas la
discussion elle est partie pour être un
peu mécanique avec des amendements qui
s'enchaînent et des réponses qui
s'enchaînent pas de 49,3 nom et la
république remarche votre art comme un
seul homme écoutez il ya un débat
parlementaire qui démarre donc c'est
normal qu'on attende le débat
parlementaire et une commission spéciale
qui s'est constitué les députés qui
travaillent d'arrache-pied de leurs
produits
moi je suis tout à fait confiante dans
la majorité mais on va attendre aussi de
voir les avancées qu'on aura dans le
débat parlementaire
d'accord alors parce que dans la
majorité ça y'a c'est un peu quoique en
stock
non vous trouvez pas cette histoire de
congé parental pour un congé de deuil
des parents en cas de décès de leur
enfant
est-ce que c'est ne pas aussi la
traduction du fait que vous n'écoutiez
pas ou pas suffisamment vos alliés à
l'intérieur de la majorité il s'agit si
j'ai ma mémoire est bonne une
proposition qui émanait du pays
je crois que c'est parce que vous
écoutez suffisamment sur ce sujet là sur
le congé sur le congé on en a parlé tout
à l'heure je crois que c'est aussi le
défaut d'une procédure parlementaire
qu'on a regardé d'un peu trop d'un peu
trop loin peut très vite et encore une
fois on a reconnu qu'il fallait remettre
le sujet sur le métier et le texte
revient au sénat après moi j'ai vécu la
crise des gilet jaune j'étais quand je
vis à vis du grand guignol
je venais d'arriver ça nous a amené à
l'acte 2 du quinquennat je pense que
c'est effectivement important d'écouter
vous savez moi je passe beaucoup de
temps sur le terrain avec ses contrats
de transition écologique ça m'amène à me
déplacer beaucoup angers j'ai fait 30
signature de ces contrats là dans l'est
dans les dernières semaines
donc je pense que c'est effectivement
important que collectivement on soit
bien l écoute des français d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu
j'avais un comité d'accueil de
syndicalistes à 9 heures je leur ai
proposé de les recevoir je le fais
systématiquement on a parlé des
retraites
y compris d'ailleurs des choses sur
lesquelles on n'arrive pas à expliquer
parce que j'avais une dame qui me
disaient mais si on calcule plus sur les
25 meilleures années mais sur toute la
carrière c'est forcément moins bien et
j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que non la
règle de calcul changer donc c'était pas
forcément moins bien parfois vous les
cherchez les boules et chercher les
anglais ou les polémiques comme le
président de la république qui pose avec
un t-shirt qui fait l'éloge des acquis
qui te condamne les violences policières
outre sa sérieuse présents destinés
c'était un moment aussi où voilà les
du mal à vous suivre comme belloubet qui
veut réhabiliter
le délit de blasphème et puis le
président de la république qui sous
prétexte de liberté d'expression on va
défendre des dessinateurs qui condamne
les violences policières c'est un peu
bizarre quand on dit tous exactement la
même chose vous nous dites c'est
insupportable vous dites tous exactement
la même chose quand on dit des choses un
petit peu différent je dirais un ordre
républicain
non mais le président de la république
il s'en est expliqué qu'ils soutenaient
la liberté d'expression voilà c'est pas
plus que ça
voilà belloubet alors alors madame b
roubaix qui est suivie par ségolène
royal semble-t-il qui s'aident eux se
souvient le plateau de france devant
francis letellier a répondu que c'est
des propos qui viennent une jeune femme
donc ses propos c'était quoi la
condamnation de des religions général et
particulièrement de l'islam
il a promis la qui était peut-être un
peu vieux un peu vif dira vous avez été
la première femme politique et homme
politique donc à réagir sur twitter
pas du tout d'accord avec ségolène royal
pour renvoyer cette jeune milla à ses
chères études qu'elle peut pas
poursuivre parce que justement elle à
elle est bien elle est bien embarrassé
depuis non je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec madame royal parce que dans cette
histoire il ya une victime et la victime
c'est cette jeune fille
certes elle a eu des propos excessifs
même stupide sur les réseaux sociaux et
de mon temps quand j'étais jeune quand
on disait des bêtises ces bêtises on les
montre et pas à la terre entière parce
que les outils n'étaient pas là quand
vous dit des bêtises
tout le monde le sait elle a dit des
choses bêtes des vraiment je ne soutiens
pas du tout ses propos je crois qu'elle
s'est rendu compte après d'ailleurs que
son expression était mal comment ça a
déchaîné un torrent de haine
ça a déchaîné des menaces de mort des
menaces de viol elle peut plus suivre sa
scolarité normalement
certains disent que ce qui lui arrive
elle l'a bien cherché
et donc voilà pour résumer on peut pas
dire je suis charlie après les attentats
en disant chacun a droit de dire ce qui
ce qui loue ce qu'elle veut dire y
compris sur les religions le blasphème
le délit de blasphème n'existe pas en
france et après condamné cette jeune
fille ou renvoyer les deux camps dos à
dos c'est une victime c'est clair que ça
lui servira de leçon mais voilà c'est
une victime
et moi ma position c'est une position de
soutien la gauche n'est pas la hauteur
dans ce genre de combat justement pour
la liberté d'expression
elle est contradictoire dans certains
cas elle est un peu contradictoire quand
on est en position de parole publique
bien sûr la première chose qu'on doit
faire la première chose que vous
demandez aux hommes aux femmes
politiques c'est de respecter les
français et les religions est donc bien
sûr qu'on est tous en position de
respect mais quand quelqu'un s'exprime
de façon outrancière
si on n'est pas d'accord on le dit si ça
relève de la loi on poursuit et sinon on
évite de menacer de mort dont je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit clair emmanuelle
wargon vous serai candidate aux
municipales
moi je suis en soutien dans tout mon
département qui est le val de marne
je ne serai pas en tête de liste à
s'amender on a une candidate qui serait
sur le crâne talentueuse j'ai pas encore
totalement décidé si je suis sur la
liste ou pas j'aurais décidé d'ici la
fin de la sq m de communes ma commune
c'est s'amender
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur
public sénat ravi de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine dalons plus loin
nous sommes ensemble en direct jusqu'à
19 heures on va donc prendre le temps
d'analyser de questionner toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
on va d'abord le fer avec notre invité
du jour c'est franck montaugé bienvenus
vous êtes sénateur socialiste du gers
vice président de la commission des
affaires économiques vous allez réagir à
différents sujets et notamment à cette
opposition contre la réforme des
retraites jusqu'à 19h nous irons comme
tous les jours et très régulièrement en
salle des conférences pour faire réagir
d'autres sénateurs et sénatrices ce sera
aujourd'hui vous le voyez avec fanny
conquis allons plus loin c'est aussi le
club
trois intervenants qui ont des choses à
vous dire avec nous aujourd'hui style
jourdain bienvenue steve on va prolonger
avec vous cette question de la réforme
des retraites les parlementaires
fourbissent leurs armes et notamment ici
au sénat on parlera retraite obstruction
parlementaire et référendum nos soins à
toute à leur mari brémaud est avec nous
comme tous les lundis c'est notre
spécialiste europe marie-marie bienvenus
emmanuel macron en pologne un exercice
d'acrobatie diplomatique nous dit le
parisien
oui il va falloir réchauffer
l'atmosphère à ce point là bas on verra
le détail avec mon mari pierre bourgeois
est également avec mme bienvenue
marie-pierre pour la chronique des
livres politiques votre lecture de la
semaine ses chevaux payet d'un président
qui se sont donc fait l'amour et d'un
autre qui s'appelle entrée plat et
dessert
oui quel programme dans une demi-heure
notre grand débat nous reviendrons sur
cette proposition de loi déposée
aujourd'hui même par la majorité
sénatoriale de droite et du centre elle
vise à renforcer le principe de laïcité
dans la constitution l'objectif étant de
lutter contre le communautarisme
possible aussi qu'il y est une lecture
plus politique à faire de cette
initiative on fera réagir nos invités
hashtag à lpl si vous vous souhaitez
réagir sur twitter
mais d'abord donc cette nuit
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites les avocats les
médecins libéraux et d'autres ça c'est
ce qui se passe dans la rue mais il ya
une autre bataille qui se joue cette
fois au parlement
l'examen du texte a démarré en
commission avec les quelques milliers
d'amendements qu'ils attendent on voit
cela en détails avec pierre henri elles
dorment mme nouveaux jours de grève
contre la réforme des retraites alors
que les députés commencent l'examen du
texte à l'assemblée
à paris les professionnels de la santé
ainsi que les avocats se sont mobilisés
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que nous
avons nous par le cnb déposé plus de 300
amendements mais des amendements
construit et constructive pour notre
profession
les partis politiques ont déposé des
amendements contre la réforme en général
et après ce que l'on craint c'est que
dans le volume qu'ils ont déposés
sincères excuses pour envisager une
utilisation du 49 3 de la constitution
alors que les amendements à mon sens
devrait être utilisé de manière plus
ciblée ce que nous avons fait le travail
a été fait par la profession vingt-deux
mille amendements ont été déposés à
l'assemblée nationale à elle seule la
france insoumise en a déposé dix neuf
mille marc fesneau ministre des
relations avec le parlement dénonce la
stratégie d'obstruction du parti de jean
luc mélenchon et ça va dans l'absurdité
au point que il supprime les alinéas ou
en amont amène ce qu'on appelle le
minimum contributif à 1000 euros il
supprime la linea qui vise à élargir le
champ de la pénibilité au change surtout
que la manoeuvre qui est proposée par la
france insoumise avec les absurdités que
je viens de montrer